[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in tim mcmahon the espn nba
staff writer who joins us on the program
uh
do you think that the utah jazz were uh
singled out here by by lebron and
company that they
they were the last two picks rudy gobert
and uh
and mitchell donovan mitchell yeah i
mean i don't know if lebron and kd
intentionally did this i don't know if
they you know got together on plot of
this but is it
disrespect to the jazz to the team that
has the best record in the nba will it
be perceived
as disrespect in utah yeah absolutely
there's no question about it um and i
really
for rudy gobert especially he's
obviously the guy who went
dead last you know he's the guy who felt
like uh he had to wait an extra couple
of years just to get invited to
uh the all-star game and and really you
know the video game stuff come on you
think was lebron playing with the new
orleans pelicans growing up i don't know
i don't i don't i don't know i don't
know that he had too much experience
playing with the pelicans growing up
um but it kind of felt like
lebron and kd again whether it was
intentionally or not we're basically
saying
you might have the best record in the
league but you really don't belong
at the top level of the nba
yeah so using lebron's logic if luka
doncic played in utah then he wouldn't
take him because
carl malone and john stockton play there
right that's what he's telling me
yeah blame it on stockton alone for sure
yeah
um i i like this i'm not big on the
all-star weekend but if it's here and
they're willing to have some fun with
this with the
slam dunk so they're cramming the slam
dunk contest in at halftime
right yeah and not the not the most
thrilling dunk contest field that i
think we've ever seen but
such is life and alex caruso of the
lakers
turned down the invitation
yeah when uh when a six foot three white
dude
who's balding is turning down dunk
contest invitations
it's it's uh you know we've got some
issues
and you have the three-point contest
where you do have some you know you got
great shooters in there
so that that and i like watching it but
yeah the three-point contest has
significantly more sizzle than the done
content let's be honest
we all wish zion would have accepted a
dumb contest invitation that's what we
want to see and then
you know top and might throw down some
some nice stuff we wanted to see zion on
that stage and so that's
that's a bummer that he didn't take the
invitation caruso
we can live without although i might
have been interested in seeing alex
caruso
in the dunk listen to me the man can fly
and especially since you know he's he
just kind of
acknowledged that uh you know he's got a
little endorsement deal his knowledge
like going full buzz he's all
aerodynamic now he can really get up i
had a couple of things here i don't know
who's going to be traded here
feels like kyle lowry's available or
sort of available
how available is lowry and where do you
see him landing
well and and that's the big question
because at this point it does not look
like bradley deal will be available so
kyle lowry would then become uh you know
the most impactful player potentially
on the trade market and you know when
when you look at
fits for him the one that really stands
out
is philly and not just because he's from
there not because
he's a nova guy although that's a nice
little story line but
simply because of how he would fit with
the 76ers how he
would fit giving a a third star to a
team that obviously has joel embiid
playing at a
mvp level you know ben simmons uh
and also you know daryl mori is
as aggressive as any uh you know
personnel executive in the league
in terms of in-season trades he he tried
to make the hardened trade happen
that didn't you know lowry would not
require giving up ben simmons but i
fully expect
daryl mori will make an aggressive pitch
because you know the 76ers are one of
these
handful of teams that obviously have a
legitimate shot at winning a
championship this season
nba analyst greg anthony was on the show
on wednesday he disagreed with me saying
that uh this was a two-way street with
the rockets
they also quit on james harden and vice
versa i know you did a deep dive on this
but um a separate fact from fiction here
with what went on i i said i can't i
couldn't vote for harden if i had a vote
for mvp because he quit on the rockets
he showed up out of shape
he did not want to be there and this is
a team that he helped build
and deconstruct and now i'm going to
have him as mvp in the same season i
can't i can't see it happening so
what did you find out with your deep
dive i mean look i i understand what
you're saying and
obviously it was a bad look the way that
uh that he
he gave up on the rockets but i also
think if you have an mvp
vote you have to just evaluate based on
pure value and his value to the brooklyn
nets uh
i think you have to include james harden
in that conversation
i wouldn't say that the rockets quit on
harden i
i think you can definitely uh you know
take a look at some of the
some of the moves they made some of the
moves they didn't make you know not
going into the luxury tax
uh his last few years and and you can
nitpick it but they were
you know they were trying like you know
this summer they were aggressive trying
to kind of remodel the roster getting
christian wood hoping they could
convince mistake
but obviously there was just no hope but
again if you talk about what really went
wrong
with the rockets what was kind of the
move that that uh
you know had this whole thing tumbling
down it was giving up chris paul and a
whole bunch of picks for russell
westbrook and
james harden not only was on board with
that but he was pounding the table
uh wanting it to happen yeah that's
where i i don't have any
sympathy not that harden's looking for
it but you wanted these players you
wanted to get rid of these players
and so is he playing at an all-star
mvp absolutely yeah but that doesn't
mean
he should be the mvp it feels like
you know earlier and earlier in the
season we're looking at mvp candidates
tim and maybe this is just
sports talk radio we need content with
the nfl we start talking about the mvp
usually after what the first month of
the season
um you know trying to handicap this
the jokic has been wonderful in denver
embiid has been great
harden you can throw him in there lebron
i know it's really important to him but
when it comes down to the mvp what is
the
this guy has to have this to get my mvp
vote
yeah damian lillard's the guy you didn't
mention i think has to be in that
discussion look
this is all ridiculously premature but
it's not
it's not media driven it's player driven
as well i mean how lebron started
lobbying for this
mvp when he was still in the bubble
complaining about last year's mvp
so don't blame the media on this one oh
no no no we we get blamed for this tim
because
just because lebron said it doesn't mean
we have to pick up the baton and keep
running
look we we okay well
we will give them the assist all right
at the minimum but you know these guys
are lobbying themselves so
um right a couple weeks ago i would have
said lebron anthony davis went out
obviously the lakers
have taken a dip here um my first
half mvp would be joel embiid
he's averaging 30 and 10. he's a major
impact player on the defense bin the
sixers have the best record
in the league and his last statement
going to the all-star break
was 40 and 19 against uh you know rudy
goldberg the team with the best record
in the league
hitting the clutch three to send that
thing into overtime and then not only
has he
uh been the best center in the nba but
he's one of the best referees he got
donald
mitchell so you know how do you not go
with that
why is it that i look at embiid the way
i do james harden and he'll never be in
as good enough
shape as i think he should be but he is
still
incredible he might be in great shape
tim i just don't know if he's ever going
to look like he's in great shape
yeah and it's funny if you look at him
early in his career he was definitely
leaner and
look the thing with embiid is can he
play
the vast majority of the games and you
know can he finish games strong
and so far this season that's happened
but you know embiid's a guy
you know a lot of these guys they like
to complain about the boating of you
know
for him in particular it's all nba last
year had to go bear get over
dude you missed 20 something games and
your team finished six in the in
in you know in the conference the 76ers
were disappointing last season so
if embiid continues producing like he is
if the sixers can fight off the net stay
atop the the eastern conference and he
you know to do that he's going to have
to play
the vast majority games i think right
now you know he would be number one on
my ballot
what's the update on anthony davis uh
you know we will see uh you know
obviously that's a situation where
you know what for the lakers this the
seating isn't really important
you know if they're a three four five
seat even
going in the western conference playoffs
if they have lebron james and anthony
davis healthy
they're going to feel like they're the
team to beat and you know what i would
agree with them so
you know i don't know what the exact
timetable for ad is
coming back after the all-star break but
i do know that the lakers aren't going
to rush him they're thinking long-term
as they should
yeah i know this is headline-worthy but
if they don't have anthony davis they're
not winning the championship this year
and you know whatever it is like this is
true load management for somebody
who needs load management with anthony
davis have
the supporting cast has the supporting
cast for the lakers
lived up to its billing no i mean look
they've been a disappointment since uh
since ad
went down there there's you know there's
no question about that
um you know there's too much on the
bronze plate he hasn't been able to
you know this was a chance for lebron to
kind of you know
really enhance his mvp uh case that that
hasn't happened as well but the just the
piece or marcus all's been a
disappointment there
you know marc gasol looks like a guy who
has had a great career but
you know it is out of gas at this point
you know we'll see if that changes
in the second half of the season montres
harrell is a guy with warts you know
he's
there's a reason that after he got six
man the year the
the clippers were just fine let him walk
across the hallway
uh you know the fact that he's playing
19 minutes in a game where
anthony davis uh you know is wearing
sweats on the bench i think that tells
you a lot
and so you know they are not invincible
but again if they d and lebron are
healthy uh they can have some warts for
that supporting cast and that's still
the team that i would put my money on
if they're completely healthy and the
nets are completely healthy
you like the lakers over the nets i i
would just because
my general philosophy uh on on the nba
is if lebron has a legitimate all-nba
co-star i don't bet against him you know
if he's healthy that's a legitimate
all-nba co-star
uh i'm not betting against him and you
know the the nets
uh i mean offensively they are
unbelievable
um but you know we'll see about their
health as well you know kd obviously
uh it has been banged up kyrie is not
exactly the most durable star
uh in the league uh you know we'll see
how they're how they're looking going
playoffs but no the nets
obviously are forced to be reckoned with
and
i think you know statistically and just
by the eye test
the best offensive team that we've seen
tim good to talk to you have fun at the
all-star weekend we appreciate your time
as always
i appreciate you having me that's tim
mcmahon espn nba staff writer and did a
deep dive on the rockets divorce
from james harden